I just remember trying to wake up and
everything's really quiet and I was no I
couldn't feel my body I see a little bit
of light but I knew I wasn't breathing
there's no pain had no feeling no pain
or anything at all but I knew I didn't
have any oxygen in my system Doug
doesn't realize that both he and Susan
have been hit by lightning
my body hit the ground and I kind of
bounced and it was going through me it
was hot and it was searing just
squatting
and my body was humming vibrating it was
like I was underwater at the swimming
pool looking out and everything was
distorted
it was like I was in an energy field
just surrounded and trapped to the
ground
surprisingly enough I wasn't I didn't
think I was going to die
Susan is lying on a bed of ale and I
thought it was odd I couldn't feel how
cold it was and that's when I realized I
was paralyzed from my shoulders I could
move my head but the rest of my body now
still he could not function and I had no
idea that it hit him too
I couldn't feel anything I thought maybe
I was dreaming when you're reading that
semi state but you're almost awake but
you're still dreaming
I just knew I needed air I'm still numb
and my legs are paralyzed my arms
paralyzed I couldn't feel my chest and I
couldn't even swallow at that point
probably got a breath few minutes later
I was able to move my neck and then I
could see her Doug is still partially
paralyzed
she was looking at me and she was
yelling at me a saying like I couldn't
hear you guys - what
Sheila's I told you we shouldn't have
stood by that tree
he was just tatters just his clothing
was just shreds this poncho there was
nothing left really but just the
neckline his t-shirt he had a hole in it
around his belt buckle area and his hat
was just blown up
it was just shredded
I didn't want to leave him because they
didn't know what was wrong with him but
I also knew that we needed desperately
to get somebody because then I knew I
was really cold
like a bolt from the blue help arrives
we were just coming out of the woods
into the clearing in I we barely saw her
Gary and Marsha Muncie are caught in the
same storm
Doug was down and there was a problem
it's disoriented you could see if he was
all burned up in front of his t-shirt we
took his pulse and it was kind of
erratic and the back of his head it you
don't have hair left worked or it burned
some hair office off his head and he was
he was in trouble